this gets over with
waddle round please
pictures up slate it and roll sound
that's be : camera let me know hi my
name is Justin are Bobby
I am the location sound mixer / boom
operator for this project
deadly reunion it's a film from James
Coen Bress ik and yeah happy to be here
half-speed right now guys just to feel
through go ahead so I was asked to talk
a little bit about my gear what I'm
working with here is a zoom h6 a lot of
people know about the h4n it's kind of
like a DIY flagship sound recorder but
the h6 came out I think in the last year
maybe in the last two years and it has
like a significantly better signal noise
ratio so I can actually live with it on
a set like this on a feature and then in
addition to the h6 i have here a
juicedlink rig eAssist
and that provides me with an even
sweeter feed for the for the boom as
well as a backup stream at negative 16
DB which is essentially like insurance
in the case of something you know clips
being on a horror film we experience a
lot of like fluctuation and dynamics so
you know in case of clipping and stuff
there's always a backup stream providing
a lower volume so that you know I don't
have to go back and disrupt the whole
process and everything and you know
re-roll on account of the sound and then
here's a rode ntg3 shotgun mic which is
up it's close it's pretty much a pro mic
so yeah yeah that's what I'm working
with here body I didn't have any of this
when I first got here so in total I was
probably spent around like four or five
thousand but it's kind of a blurry
because I mean I'm including my home
studio equipment as well so but for this
I feel like this mic is 700
the zoom is I think is like 4 to 500 the
preamp the juicedlink is 400 these
headphones their Sennheiser but they're
just like super cheap headphones I think
they're like 30 bucks you can get them
at like Samy's camera yeah and then I
have oh I forgot to mention my lobs my
Sennheiser g3 lobs which go for about
700 per system there's a transmitter
receiver and then they come with a
microphone and I have two of those
mm-hmm Jill here in my man can I have
you just kind of gangster for a second
we have some tips don't look at me that
solo voice
one more underneath the wheel we're not
saying to grab just batteries I was
carted very good back it Chuck this
kinda into your pipe is cool thank you
originally I thought I could get away
with just having this preamp because it
goes direct input into the camera so it
has a 3.5 millimeter output that I can
plug into the directly into the camera
but that would require me to carry
around a DSLR which I thought I could
get away with because I started out just
shooting like comedy sketches and stuff
for like UCB so it's kind of like a
low-level just like relaxed environments
people don't really care too much but
then at a certain point I started to
realize like it's a little ridiculous to
have this rig I'm like there's a camera
hanging around my neck with like a lens
cap on it people are like I don't know
are you a camera guy or sound guy I
don't know and so you know I just
started realizing like kind of let's
step into the more professional tier and
that was one of the things I needed to
do was get this h6
so that I wouldn't have such a silly
setup
okay starting here about that nice it
always depends if you're really at your
beginning stages then any step towards
getting your own gear is in the right
direction but if you do it if you want
to work with a semi-professional and in
a semi-professional realm it won't suit
you to kind of you know and to show up
with that kind of gear because you'll
you'll regret it it'll sting a little
bit
you know you'll feel it from the
production like what I thought you're
gonna bring some real gear dude and you
know it doesn't doesn't fly so it
depends on it depends on what you're
going for but you know that's that's one
way to learn your lesson and sometimes
that's necessary so I met Chuck Pappas
our DP on a comedy sketch shoot for
Funny or Die the the sketch group is
called white women and it was kind of
like a rap battle that gone wrong
so the guys like battling another guy
and he takes it too far and the one guy
starts like tear it up it gets like real
sad and so yeah me and Chuck kind of
like became fast friends on that shoot
and he threw me a rope now I'm here and
I'm really glad because this is a really
cool crew and you know it's been a lot
of fun